- Made the flight.
I don't know how.
Ran, did cardio.
Next stop, Cannes.
(upbeat music)
Alright, here in Cannes.
Week of tons of meetings.
The entire advertising industry
globally gets together here
especially on the
creative side but ad tech,
Fortune 500 clients.
For me what's crazy is I'm able
to get an enormous amount of
meetings in during this week
which probably
saves me 7 to 10 days
in the second half of the
year of not having to fly to
Chicago or L.A. or San Francisco
or even, believe
it or not, New York.
I tend to see some
people here more
than I see them in New York.
Just when you get to
that level of busyness,
you know, sometimes events like
this are just
more efficient, right?
So, we'll do that.
I'm looking forward to it.
Should be really,
really productive.
Got a bunch of my team here.
Kim Garcia from
Vayner Experience,
crushed it.
Excited about our Experience
Division of events that we put
on and events that we activate
for clients and it should just
be really good. Excited.
Alright, cleaned up here a
little bit in the boat bathroom.
Fully in the Cannes mode now
and super fired up
to do our first
event here at the VaynerX boat.
VaynerX is our
holding company that holds
PureWow and VaynerMedia.
We're here in Cannes.
We've got a
bunch of activations.
Ryan Harwood, CEO
of PureWow is here.
- Excited to be here.
- Which means
everything will be okay.
(Ryan laughs)
Row of bunch
of boats to the left
and to the right.
Some people
massively overdressed.
Right there, those characters.
Going to do some panels now.
You wore a sports jacket?
- I was like this is not good.
Not gonna work this time.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] Tommy B!
What up, baby?
How are you?
- I'm very well.
Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] What's your name?
- Joelle.
- [Gary] Joelle.
- Will. (inaudible)
- How are things?
- Very well. Very well.
- Good.
- [Tom] Way better
dressed than I am dude.
Don't know what I was thinking.
I'm wearing board shorts.
- Dude, the rave
is about to start, Tom.
You're good.
You're good, brother.
I actually think
it's one macro which is
this is a binary conversation.
Either an organization cares
about it's employees
or it doesn't.
And by the way I actually
think the way to hack this is to
actually make this a
CFO issue not an HR issue.
I think when people
actually understand at
the highest levels that it's...
Listen, I'm a good guy and I
like people but like the reason
I'm obsessive about
retention is it creates speed.
People know each other,
cadence and speed wins.
You know, business is sports.
Speed wins and so for me, when
we announced Claude as our
Chief Heart Officer and I started
doing more stuff on HR and just
gave a big speech in
San Francisco around HR
when I talk about people
I try to make it more of
a CFO conversation because
if you don't it's fluffy,
it's emotional,
it's nice to have.
If you make it financial,
everybody starts
paying attention.
So to me, you
level it up to why.
Maybe you give somebody a
raise that you don't want to or
you give them tickets to a
Cardinals game or
you buy them some sneakers
that they've been liking on
Pinterest or Instagram.
It shows that you care
and that leads to retention.
The biggest reason I spend so
much time one on one with all
the faces I see here.
People that are still here,
people that used to work for me
is 'cause that caring
ROI plays out in a macro.
Shelly spoke to it.
I mean, you will never find
somebody who's won that ever
talks about short term return.
Everybody who's winning is
thinking long term because
the ironic thing is business
life and life in general,
hopefully is long if nothing
crazy happens is a marathon.
Yet, everybody's running
around like it's a sprint.
Trying to make something happen
in 30 or 90 or 180 day window.
I think the hack is can you
get into the ear of the CFO?
Can she or he
really realize, holy shit,
this actually matters
more than you think.
And I think one of the, I invest
in a company called HiQ which is
real big data
analyzation of all this.
The cost of replacing engineers
in Silicon Valley
is so ridiculous.
Even for me, with the
people that I interact with,
even if they're mid-tier
managers the emotional cost of
replacement is pretty extreme
and so that's
where I would go with it.
(upbeat music)
I think I speak about
regret so much 'cause
I'm so fearful of it.
I love life so much that when
I'm 84 and I know I don't have
30 years left, I'm gonna be sad.
The reason I tell
you this is you're young.
I don't know what you're
expenses are or debt is, right?
But the bottom line is,
it's always easier
now than it is tomorrow.
- [Joelle] Yeah.
- [Gary] It just is.
- [Joelle] I told you,
I was shaking your hand--
- Done! Done!
- [Joelle] I'm gonna implement
and I know what you're like
and I know you're
gonna hold me to it.
- What's even crazier
is I would fuckin' hire you
if your startup fails.
I would flat out do it.
Just for the story,
we would run this video.
You know?
- [Joelle] Alright, I love that.
- Good luck to you.
- [Joelle] Thanks very much.
- Thanks for stopping by.
Cheers, mate. Stay well.
Hi. I'm glad you came.
Really good to see you.
(crosstalk)
How are things?
- [Woman] Nadine Kaiser.
- Nadine, how are you?
- [Woman] Nadine's actually
one of your neighbors.
She's (censored).
(upbeat music)
- [DRock] How'd the panel go?
- Panel went super well.
Shelly's a beast.
Straight winner.
Important issue.
You know, diversity and
inclusion is not about checking
a box of being
politically correct.
It's the smart
fuckin' strategy to win.
(indistinct chatter)
I'll be right back up.
Hey, hey. First one down.
(upbeat music)
And Dog is in the building.
Looking good, Dog.
- [Dennis] Dennis
Ossipov-Grodsky,
universally known as Dog.
(laughs) Edit that.
- [DRock] What's the most
valuable thing you've learned
while working with Gary?
- To be honest with you,
I think he embodies change.
Change has been a
beaten up word, right?
Everybody talks about change.
I've been to companies
that did talk change
but change took forever
and market course
corrected them and with Gary
I think he embodies change
and he imposes that mentality
organically, by the way, on
the rest of the organization.
And I have not seen an
organization that was more
nimble and flexible
in accepting change.
Pivoting, adjusting, adjusting
to the market conditions,
adjusting to his vision,
right, because he has incredible
intuition and
proving it right or wrong.
So I think it's also important
to not to be precious about your
change because change comes.
Sometimes it's the right change,
sometimes it's semi-right change,
sometimes it's outright wrong.
So it's very important for
organization to be able to go
into that change, test it
out and say two months later,
"You know what?
"It was a mistake,
we're pulling out.
"We're changing it."
So change.
- I think, and it's such a
cliche and it's something that
he says all the time,
but I think it's a
marathon and not a sprint.
I think this week at Cannes is
actually probably one of the
best representations of that.
You know when
you think about it,
there's a lot of different
people that we're gonna be
meeting from a lot of different
companies and a lot of people
here are thinking
more transactional.
What's the short
term opportunity?
How do I sell them today?
How do I close the deal?
Where the way that I'm thinking
about it and it's really what
I've learned from Gary is how
do I actually build a genuine
relationship with this person
with the idea that we might not
do anything
together for two, three,
four, ten years.
But ultimately, I might want to
recruit that person
ten years from now.
Or I might want to do a
deal ten years down the line.
Or they're gonna go
talk to their friend and say,
"Hey, I just met
with the VaynerMedia team.
"They're really, really smart.
"You should be thinking
about what they're doing."
And so it's really just coming
at it with a long game mentality
versus how do I make
the most money or
close the deal
in the short term.
Which is a total mind shift for
most people because they're in
it for the short game
versus kinda the
30, 40, 60 year game plan.
- At the party,
Maverick doing his thing.
Bunch of big wigs.
Kelly McCarthy.
She helped me build
VaynerMedia in the early days.
Mav Carter, one of
the great executives,
LeBron's boy.
Hustlin' at this event,
making shit happen.
Alright, it's getting
late in the night.
Alex Castlin looks homeless.
We've established that.
Ryan Harwood looks like
he ate a good amount tonight.
- Oh!
- We've made some stuff done.
Bunch of the peeps.
Productive meetings.
Ryan, productive?
Kristin, you out?
- Over.
- And out.
(upbeat music)